Professor John Merriman:
Well, I'm not working today.
Moi, je chome aujourd'hui,
je ne fais rien.
It's a great pleasure to have
my wonderful colleague and great
friend Bruno Cabanes,
who is going to do give a
lecture today on "The Great War,
Grief and Memory;"
and he's the author of a really
terrific book called,
in English, Victory Plunged
into Mourning,
on what happened at the end of
the war to the soldiers and to
France.
And he has just published-- I
just received it a few minutes
ago-- the Larousse de la
Grande Guerre,
under his editorship,
along with Anne Duménil.
Voilà,
je te prête la machine
là.
Professor Bruno Cabanes:
Thanks, John.
This is my pleasure to give
this class today on the "The
Great War, Grief and Memory."
As a kind of introduction I
would like to start with a book
that Sigmund Freud wrote in
1915, Thoughts for the Times
on War and Death.
And according to me this is
probably one of the most
fascinating works written on
mass death and collective
mourning during the Great War.
Freud described,
and I would like to quote,
"the complete collapse when
death has struck down someone
whom we love,
a parent or a partner in
marriage, a brother or a sister,
a child or a close friend.
Our hopes," he says,
"our hopes, desires and our
pleasures lie in the grave with
them.
We will not become souls,
we will not fill the lost one's
place."
Actually, mass death and its
consequence, generalized
mourning, appeared well before
the end of the war.
To give you only one example,
around fifty percent of the
French soldiers killed during
the Great War lost their lives
in a seventeen-month period
between August 1914 and December
1915.
Four years later,
in 1918/1919,
so in the immediate aftermath
of war, death was basically
everywhere--the names written on
the war memorials built in the
early 1920s,
the black dresses of the war
widows, the empty spaces left by
so many young men,
all over Europe and all over
the world.
We all know,
you all know,
from a demographic perspective
how deadly the Great War was.
Around nine million soldiers
killed: two million Germans,
1.8 million Russians,
1.4 million French.
And to the dead of the Great
War one must also add all those
killed by the pandemic of the
Spanish flu--maybe two or three
times more murderous than World
War I;
probably twenty million people
were actually killed by the
Spanish flu epidemic in 1918.
So, we all know these figures.
But, according to me,
they mean nothing if one does
not consider them in the
relationship with private and
collective mourning;
and that's the topic of today's
class.
Studying private and collective
mourning is, of course,
much more difficult than
studying mass death from the
perspective of historical
demography,
because most of the time this
personal, very personal,
very intimate and family
experience of mourning has not
left many sources.
So, the challenge for
historians is actually to grasp
the mourning process in its
reality,
something equivalent to what
the German sculptress Käthe
Kollwitz did when she made these
two granite statues representing
her husband,
Karl, and herself,
mourning their son Peter who
was killed in Belgium near the
city of Ypres in October 1914.
Of course, historians are not
sculptors, historians are not
artists, unfortunately.
So, how do we study private and
collective mourning?
That's what I would like to
examine with you in this class.
In the first part of my
discussion I would like to--my
perspective will be rather
general.
In the aftermath of World War
One, who were the people in
mourning, I will ask,
and how many of them were
there?
But otherwise this question
touches on the possibility of
studying what Jay Winter once
called "communities in
mourning,"
a very forward-looking concept
that he's using mostly for Great
Britain and for the U.S.
In the second part of this
class I will examine the
specificity of mourning in the
aftermath of World War One.
In doing so I hope to show you
that mourning can be studied
from a comparative perspective,
and that despite their
personal, emotional dimensions,
war bereavements after the
Great War actually have some
characteristics in common.
And lastly, I will end my class
by examining the mourning
process in itself,
and in doing so I would like to
study the relationship between
personal suffering and
collective mourning;
in other words,
the transformation of grief
into a cultural process.
So, let's start with my first
point.
Who were the persons in
mourning after World War One?
Well, from the perspective of
historical demographics this
question is actually a very
difficult one.
Why?
Because in France,
in the '20s and '30s,
war widows who remarried lost
their benefits and so simply
vanished from the statistics.
And if you take the case of the
orphans, they got some help from
the French state when they were
children, but not when they came
of age;
consequently the number you
find in most textbooks of around
600,000 widows and at least
760,00 orphans in France in the
1920s is of course only a rough
estimate.
And this is not to mention the
grandparents,
the brothers,
the sisters,
the uncles,
the aunts, the nephews or
cousins who were in mourning,
too, and sometimes expressed in
very moving diaries,
in very moving letters,
in very moving other sources
their sufferings.
So, the concept of communities
in mourning, coined by Jay
Winter, is a very useful one as
a means to grasp the scale of
mourning after World War One in
its entirety.
Actually, every institution,
every social structure went
into mourning in the aftermath
of World War One.
The French high schools,
the French
lycées,
the French universities,
the French companies,
the French businesses,
as well as let's say the French
athletic clubs or the French
football teams,
the dead might have their names
inscribed in a number of
places-- their schools,
their former colleges,
their parish churches.
The social structures were
themselves communities of
mourning, were themselves
composed of various groups
affected by mourning in varying
degrees,
depending on their relationship
with the deceased when he was
still alive.
And that's the second notion
that I would like actually to
introduce, what the French
historian Stéphane
Audoin-Rouzeau once called "the
circles of mourning."
The first circle of mourning
was composed of soldiers
themselves.
For obvious reasons,
on November 11th,
1918, the French Army was not
only a victorious one but also
an army in mourning;
mourning the dead as much as
rejoicing for victory.
What did the soldiers do on
Armistice Day,
November 11th,
1918?
They first tried to find the
bodies of those who had been
abandoned in an immense land.
They buried them and they
decorated with flowers the
wooden crosses,
like this one,
that marked individual graves
on the battlefields.
I wanted to quote a letter of a
French soldier sent to his wife:
"my regiment has suffered
terrible losses."
So, it was written on Armistice
Day.
"My regiment has suffered
terrible losses.
Many of my friends have been
killed without ever knowing the
joy of victory.
Thinking about those poor souls
I feel terrible."
Those who are still waiting for
news from members of their
family, who were still fighting,
wanted first to be reassured
before being able to rejoice.
Take the example of Henri
Fauconnier, who volunteered in
the summer of 1914 at the age of
thirty-five,
and whose fascinating
correspondence with his young
fiancée Madeline has been
published just a few years ago,
Lettres à
Madeline.
And I quote,
"how I am longing now to have
some news of Calot,
of Jean," he wrote,
"I will not be completely happy
until then."
And those who had lost friends,
those who had lost brothers,
who also had lost comrades in
arms during the war,
often expressed what has been
later diagnosed as the
survivor's syndrome,
a notion coined in the 1960s by
the psychiatrist Niederland.
And here I would like to quote
Pierre Drieu la Rochelle in his
novel La Comédie de
Charleroi,
published just after the war.
"At certain moments I
experienced a kind of shame,
as though I had torn the days I
was enjoying now from those
young men whom I had left
behind."
Guilt, shame,
anxiety, sadness,
these were actually the
feelings of most French soldiers
in November 1918.
So, that's the first circle of
mourning.
And this first circle of
mourning was actually in close
contact with a second circle of
mourning, relatives of their
dead comrades.
The soldiers,
as you may know,
used to inform the families of
the precise location of the
burial place,
including sometimes the
photographs, sometimes a map,
sometimes a description so that
the bodies could be found and
reburied after the war.
They described the dead
soldier's last moments,
they described the funeral
tribute that had been made.
Actually, in doing so,
the first circle of mourning,
the small primary group,
worked as a kind of fictitious
family, a substitute for the
relatives who were not present
when the soldier was killed.
And the second circle of
mourning was composed of the
soldier's parents,
the grandparents,
the children,
the wife and also larger family
group, uncles,
aunts, cousins,
nieces, nephews.
Most of the time,
I must admit,
this larger family group has
been underestimated because
actually it appears in very rare
sources.
And just to mention one of
these very interesting sources,
that's the war diary written by
the young Françoise
Marette.
You probably don't know her,
but you know probably a name
when she will become one of the
most famous child psychiatrists
in France,
Françoise Dolto.
So, the young Françoise
Marette had actually been
educated in a very Catholic
family and she was brought up
with the idea that she should
pray every day for her young
uncle who had been sent to the
front.
So, she had been brought up
with the idea that in some ways
it was her duty,
as a child, and I would say as
a young girl,
which is not the same,
as a young girl,
to do so.
But it was actually her way to
take part in the conflict.
And, as you can imagine,
the death of her dear uncle
adds a traumatic impact in the
life of this young
Françoise Marette.
In a diary she presents herself
comme une veuve de
guerre, as a war widow,
and her grief is presented as a
personal tragedy.
So, that's a second circle of
mourning.
And you've got actually a third
one, which is of course much
more difficult to study,
which is made up of friends.
I don't know if you will be
interested.
I think the history of
friendship, especially the
history of friendship in
wartime, is actually a
fascinating one which still
needs to be written.
So, if you have a theory or
something to write about that,
it's a wonderful topic,
the history of friendship in
wartime;
and especially from the
perspective of her history of
bereavement.
It has been only partially
studied for a small group of
students;
in the English case for
students from Oxford and
Cambridge, and in the French
case for students from the
École Normale
Supérieure who lost
actually hundreds of friends
during the war,
and who used to write short but
very personal biographies in the
École's year book.
Take, for example,
this obituary written by the
novelist Maurice Genevoix.
You must already know him,
he's one of the most famous
writers of the Great War.
So, it was written by the
novelist Maurice Genevoix for
one of his friends killed at the
age of twenty-five,
in January 1915,
and I quote,
"what so often during those
long months of war,
and each engagement had created
voids around me.
All the good friends at the
beginning whom I'd chosen,
who had lightened my hours and
to whom I wanted to give back
the strength they had given me,
had fallen, one after the one,
all of them,
until I was alone in a crowd of
indifferent men.
And among those whose support I
wished for, to make this cult of
the dead more fervent,
was Benoit, dearest to my heart
and most valued friend.
I said to myself,
'he, at least,
will be saved.'
And I believed it.
Then one morning in the white
hospital room the male orderly
handed me a card and on this
card I read 'Benoit is dead.'
I felt a crushing sorrow.
I could not understand it,
it did not make sense."
Well, of course,
this absence of meaning,
this absurdity can be explained
by the experience of war itself
but it also leads us to the
second point I would like to
discuss with you today:
the specificity,
if there is any,
of the experience of World War
One.
The first specificity,
according to me,
is that for the first time
death in combat reversed the
normal succession of
generations;
and not on a limited scale,
rather on the scale of the
whole generation,
la generation perdue,
the lost generation.
There were often feelings of
shame, feelings of guilt towards
the younger men who were almost
exclusively bearing the burden
of war and death.
As my colleague Jay Winter
pointed out in a
thought-provoking article on
wartime demography published
some years ago,
many older people in Paris,
in London, in Berlin,
were suffering from depression
during the Great War.
And you've got the very famous
case of the sociologist Emile
Durkheim, who died of grief;
he died of grief only one year
after his son's death in
December 1915.
So, the reverse of the normal
succession of generations was
seen as shocking,
not only during the war,
not only in the immediate
aftermath of war,
but also years later.
I want to quote an amazing page
from the last novel--you
probably know it,
it's probably one of the most
wonderful books written by
Albert Camus,
Le Premier Homme,
The First Man,
a copy of which,
as you may know,
was filmed in a briefcase near
the car in which the novelist
died in January 1960,
at the age of forty-six.
In 1953 Albert Camus made a
pilgrimage to the cemetery in
Brittany where his father lay.
He filmed the grave,
in the first row of the
military section of the Saint
Michel Cemetery at Saint-Brieuc,
and there he read the date,
and I quote,
"1885-1914," and automatically
he did the arithmetic,
twenty-nine years.
Suddenly he was struck by an
idea that shook his very being.
He was forty-years-old.
The man buried under that slab
who had been his father was
actually younger than him,
and the wave of tenderness and
pity that once filled his heart
was not the stirring of the soul
that leads the son to the memory
of the vanished father,
but the overwhelming compassion
that a grown man feels for an
unjustly murdered child;
something here was not in the
natural order,
and in truth there was no order
but only madness and chaos when
the son was older than the
father.
Second specificity:
death was also experienced by
the soldiers in a very solitary
way.
Well, you'll tell me it's of
course very common in wartime.
But here it must be seen
specifically in the light of
both the extreme violence of
this war and in the light of the
religious rituals that were
still very important in France,
before the outbreak of World
War One.
One of the most striking fears
experienced by the soldiers of
the Great War was of dying
alone,
in the midst of an immense
land, abandoned by their
comrades because of the violence
of the battle,
without a truce for
stretcher-bearers;
or because the short,
unofficial truces were too
precarious, soldiers who fell
wounded between the lines lay
dying for hours,
sometimes days.
According to the military
historian John Keegan,
one-third of the 20,000 men who
died on the Somme on July 1st,
1916, might have been saved had
the wounded soldiers been aided,
as they probably would have
been half a century earlier.
So, this fear of dying alone
was something many relatives
actually imagined for their
loved ones,
and which added,
of course, another torment to
their bereavement.
Imaging their loved ones dying
in almost animal solitude was
something unbearable.
And I would like to quote a war
diary published in 1919 by a war
widow: "He dies all alone over
there like a dog,
and this horrible,
pitiful death we call death on
the field of honor.
He will lie for days and days
forgotten, on the bare earth,
with a smashed skull and chest,
and German crows will steal
away his dearest memories."
Obviously, this solitary death
was all the more unbearable as
dying was not the socially
invisible reality it has become
in the late twentieth century,
but something accepted,
something experienced at home,
in the company of relatives and
friends.
And if you want to understand
this process you have to read
the work by the sociologist
Norbert Elias which is probably
his last book,
published I think in 1982,
The Loneliness of Dying,
in which he presents this
process from once again the
death experienced at home to a
kind of invisible and a solitary
death we experience right now,
today.
So, before World War One only
those who had no family,
only those who had no home,
will die alone or will die in
the hospital.
The funeral vigil was also very
important and a very respected
ritual in a Catholic country
like France.
Industrialized warfare,
World War One,
changed this tradition in the
most violent and the most brutal
way.
All the stages-- and they are
very important--all the stages
that used to prepare a person
for bereavement were simply
eliminated.
All the rituals that in
ordinary life accompanied the
first moments of loss were also
eliminated.
The first specificity was the
absence of the dead bodies
during World War One,
and that for two main reasons.
The first one was the complete
destruction of around thirty
percent of those killed during
the Great War,
whose bodies were destroyed by
the explosions and could not be
identified.
In the context of total war,
direct heat from large-caliber
shells could literally pulverize
the body, leaving absolutely no
remains;
hence the great number of
missing in action during the
Great War.
If you want to understand the
experience of shelling and if
you want to understand the
psychological sufferings
inflicted to the soldiers,
you must read what the Jesuit
Paul Dubreuil,
a veteran of Verdun,
wrote about the Battle of
Verdun in 1916,
and I quote,
"when one heard the whistle in
the distance one's whole body
contracted to resist the two
excessively important vibrations
of the explosion,
and at each repetition it was a
new attack, a new fatigue,
a new suffering.
Under this regime the most
solid nerves cannot resist for
long.
Perhaps the best comparison is
that of seasickness,
and that's my point,
to die from bullets seems to be
nothing.
Parts of our being remain
intact but to be dismembered,
torn to pieces,
reduced to pulp,
this is a fear that flesh
cannot support and which is
fundamentally the great
suffering of the bombardment."
But there is also another
reason for the absence of dead
bodies which is often less
known.
After 1918, the bodies remained
on the battlefields,
until the French governments
gave permission to repatriate
them.
But this did not happen before
a special decree was passed in
1920, so two years after the end
of World War One.
Why did it take so much time to
allow the French families to get
their loved one's bodies back
home for private burial?
Nobody knows,
but the enormous amount of
energy many French families
spent to have this decree
finally signed shows in itself
the psychological sufferings
caused by distance and prolonged
absence.
Well, that's something we all
know from everyday life.
For example,
in the case of the sailors lost
at sea or from recent events,
for example the victims of the
9/11 attacks,
ending the mourning process
without having seen,
touched, or kissed,
or buried a body,
is extremely difficult,
almost impossible.
And that's actually something
thousands and thousands of
families experienced after World
War One.
That's also something the
French politician Louis Barthou
explained before the National
Commission on Military Burials
on May 31st,
1919, when the government,
the French government still
opposed the return of the
soldiers' remains.
And I quote,
"fine, it's all very well to
say that our children will be
equal in death.
But I don't see what principle
of equality requires that a hard
and fast rule be established as
far as families is concerned.
Where is my son?
He was killed in 1914,
five years ago.
He's in a tomb.
His mother and I are waiting
for him.
And because horrors have not
been found you tell me that you
forbid me to take my son and
bring him to the
Père-Lachaise Cemetery,"
which is, as you may know one
of the largest cemeteries in
Paris.
"Well, I tell you that you have
no right to do so.
You explain it by saying that
hundreds of thousands of
soldiers have been killed and
you have not identified them.
But mine was.
You speak of identification.
Well mine was identified.
Of the transportation shortage;
but I can bring back my son on
my own, without asking anything
of the government.
This is not what I understand
by equality and I think the
proposed government bill is a
mistake.
That's why I,
for my part,
won't accept it."
As a consequence of the
specificities I have just
presented, the mourning process
after World War One was an
incredibly difficult and
tortuous one,
and it gave birth to a new
commemorative activity,
new languages,
new rituals that I would like
to present now in my third
point.
Up to now I've addressed the
notion of grief from the
perspective of personal
bereavement.
But the expense of mass death,
the absence of so many dead
bodies, the violence of the war
experience itself also needed
new forms of representation so
that the dead soldiers could be
remembered and so that a tribute
could be paid to them.
That's what Stéphane
Andoin-Rouzeau and Annette
Becker explain in their book
1914-1918,
Understanding the Great
War.
The words spoken at ceremonies,
the images offered in
inscriptions and commemorative
monuments,
the stained-glass windows,
the cemeteries and usuries have
lasted to this day,
and through them we as
historians can recall these
endless commemorations where
political liturgy and private
bereavements were complementary.
Political liturgy ends private
bereavement, in other words
collective mourning and personal
grief.
My point here is not to present
you, of course,
the war of commemorative
activity after World War One;
that will be almost impossible
and useless.
I would prefer to focus on two
major cultural processes that
deal with the transformation of
the personal grief into
collective mourning.
The first one can be presented
as a kind of nationalization of
mourning.
In the 1920s and 1930s the
battlefields were converted into
commemorative sites through a
network of military cemeteries,
landscaped memorial parks,
and large battlefield
monuments.
A kind of war tourism appeared
during the conflict itself and
develops in the 1920s and 1930s;
just refer, if you're
interested by that topic,
to the book written by David
Lloyd,
Battlefield Tourism:
Pilgrimage and the
Commemoration of the Great War
in Britain,
Australia and Canada,
published in 1998.
These new sites of memory,
or to use the famous
terminology coined by Pierre
Nora,
these new lieux de
mémoire,
were often represented on
objects,
paintings and pictures,
and a number of ceremonies were
organized to pay tribute to the
dead,
especially on Armistice Day
each year.
And that's an object which I
like very much.
It's a bit kitsch,
of course, but it's the usury
in Douaumont,
so near Verdun,
in Verdun, which is represented
on a tray.
Can you imagine to have that at
home all the time?
Anyway, it's on a tray.
And you see exactly what
Douaumont is about.
It's a huge necropolis which
was inaugurated in summer 1932.
It's aim was at the same time
to bring together most of the
identified bodies of the Battle
of Verdun.
The cemetery here contains more
than 15,000 bodies.
And the other aim was to
contain the remains of those who
remained unidentified,
estimated as here,
estimated 32,000 inside the
building, 32,000.
So, the cemetery which appears
also in the famous 1937 remake
of J'accuse! by Abel
Gance where dead soldiers,
here the cemetery,
rise from it--can you imagine
that, too?--arise from the grave
in Douaumont,
at the Douaumont Cemetery to
haunt the living and prevent
another war.
That's really a fascinating
film.
So, the cemetery,
this cemetery of Douaumont,
and three other ones at Notre
Dame de Lorette,
in the Pas-de-Calais,
at Douaumont,
the Marne, and at [inaudible],
in Alsace,
became places of family
pilgrimage for those who had
lost a relative or for those who
had no grave to go to.
According to me,
all these commemorative sites
of memory must be considered in
the perspective of the French
national unity.
The sites of memory which
became sites of mourning for the
whole French nation,
like this one,
Douaumont, and also the 36,000
war memorials built in each of
the 36,000 communes into which
France was divided-- in every
French commune.
So, even in the smallest
village, the same day of the
year, November 11th,
at the same hour,
11 a.m., the mayor used to name
the dead.
For the lost generation,
a new entity was created that
obeyed the classical precepts of
tragedy--unity of time,
November 11th;
unity of space, the memorials;
unity of action,
the commemorative ceremony.
Naming the dead served,
as you can imagine,
another important function for
the living-- inscribing the
names of the dead,
reading them and then touching
the inscription served to bring
the dead out of the anonymity of
mass death.
And if you've been to
Washington, DC you know that
it's exactly what happens
nowadays with the VVM,
with the Vietnam Veterans
Memorial in Washington DC,
made by Maya Lin,
where the Vietnam Vets go to
touch the inscriptions and mourn
their comrades in arms.
Le lieu de
mémoire,
the oversight of memory related
to this nationalization of
mourning is,
of course, the commemorative
invention par excellence of the
Great War, the cult of the
Unknown Soldier.
In most countries,
except Germany and except
Russia, the cult of the Unknown
Soldier was extremely popular in
the 1920s.
It appeared almost at the same
time in Paris and London in
1920;
in Washington,
DC, Rome and Brussels in 1921;
and in Prague and Belgrade in
1922.
But, of course,
I would like to focus on the
French case.
What happens in November 1920?
On November 10th,
1920, the Unknown Soldier's
coffin arrived in Paris by
special train from Verdun.
The coffin was placed for one
night--and every step is
important--the coffin was placed
for one night at the Place
Denfert-Rochereau which is of
course symbolic;
and you know probably why,
because it was named,
the Place Denfert-Rochereau,
was named for a heroic French
commander of 1871,
and so it symbolized the
revenge of the French over the
Germans.
The next day,
November 11th,
1920, the Unknown Soldier was
brought to the Pantheon,
which was first considered the
natural place to bury it,
because as you may know it's
the burial place dedicated to
the nation's great men.
But according to most veterans
the Unknown Soldier was not
un grand homme,
was not a great man in the
usual meaning of the word.
So, after a brief ceremony at
the Pantheon the coffin was
brought to the Arc de Triomphe.
It had been draped with the
French flag, it had been placed
on a gun carriage,
and it was surrounded by
mutilated veterans who were
there to symbolize the destroyed
man and the destroyed families.
Furthermore,
and this is my point,
the coffin was also accompanied
by a fictitious family--a war
widow,
a mother and father who had
lost a son, and a child who had
lost his father during the war.
This as if each French man,
each French woman,
was to adopt the Unknown
Soldier as a member of his or
her family.
And the ceremonies of November
11th, 1920, brought hundreds of
thousands of weeping people into
the streets of Paris,
many encouraged to believe that
the coffin that passed actually
before them contained the body
of the man they had lost.
In other words,
the Unknown Soldier was the
dead relative of every French
family,
as well as a symbol of the loss
experienced by the French nation
as a whole.
So, that's also a kind of
nationalization of mourning.
Nationalization of mourning,
but also--and this is the
second major cultural process--a
kind of spiritualization of
mourning.
Well, I could give you many
examples of the spiritual flavor
that characterized the 1920s and
1930s.
I could also discuss,
as Jay Winter did remarkably in
his book Sites of Memory,
Sites of Mourning,
whether the spirituality of the
Great War and of the aftermath
of the Great War was something
new or something rooted in the
European religious traditions
and rituals.
I will only give you one
emblematic example,
and actually I will end my
presentation with it.
This is the case of Maurice
Gallais--that's the portrait
here--a young officer cadet who
died in Bouchavesne,
on the Somme,
on September 25th,
1916, at the age of twenty-two.
Actually, he was sent on a
reconnaissance mission and,
as he was just back from leave,
he probably didn't know the
area very well and lost his way,
and he was shot by a German
patrol.
Maurice was the only child of
Berthe and Auguste Gallais,
who owned a factory in
Creil--that's in
département of the
Oise,
close to Paris,
only thirty kilometers from
Paris.
He was unmarried,
had only a few relatives.
His immediate family included
probably seven people,
and his death was,
of course, experienced as a
terrible emotional shock for all
of them.
It actually took almost six
months before Maurice Gallais's
parents received the
confirmation that their son had
been killed.
He was first considered missing
in action, and his body was
identified only in spring 1917.
Berthe and Auguste Gallais
could not wait until the end of
the war to see the place where
their son, Maurice,
was buried.
Despite the obvious danger,
despite the restrictions
imposed by the military
authorities,
they drove to Bouchavesne,
in 1917--can you imagine that,
in 1917?--they drove to
Bouchavesne as soon as they
could and they took pictures of
the temporary grave.
In 1922, almost four years
after the armistice,
they decided to bury Maurice
for the second time.
Auguste Gallais,
his father, wrote to the mayor
of Bouchavesne,
and convinced him to build a
huge roadside cross dedicated to
the memory of the men of
Bouchavesne,
and dedicated to Maurice
himself.
So, as you can see at this
stage the personal grief is
already deeply inter-twined with
the public collective one.
In 1922 Berthe Gallais decided
also to transform Maurice's room
into a kind of mausoleum.
Some ground from the
battlefield, from the Somme,
was brought back to Creil and
exposed in a room,
along with--I don't know if you
can see that here clearly--with
fragments of shells and other
material souvenir of the Great
War.
Behind the cabinet's window,
Maurice Gallais' uniform with
the ruby-red pants of 1914,
some photographs here
representing the young man.
It's a curious gathering of
personal belongings and remains
from the war which reveal,
according to me,
a kind of fetishism.
But that's not all.
In this room,
transformed into a kind of
chapel, Maurice was represented
like a saint who had saved
France;
and as his own grandmother
wrote in a prayer,
the whole universe,
l'univers entier--not
only France, l'univers
entier.
Maurice's personal belongings
were described by Berthe
Gallais, his mother,
as some religious relics.
And this is actually what many,
many Catholic French people
felt in the '20s and '30s.
At this time,
as my colleague,
Annette Becker is explaining,
in one of her books,
the Christian soldier was
likened in his sacrifice to
Christ in a kind of imitatio
christi,
and his mother to a new Virgin
Mary, a mater dolorosa.
Until her death in 1927,
Maurice Gallais's grandmother
went every day to the room,
and recited the prayer she had
composed for him,
thanking God for having given
her such a courageous grandson,
"parce que vous l'avec
accordé
la plus belle des morts et
ouvert votre paradis,
où je l'imagine comme un
saint"--like a saint--"je
vous remercie,
Signor",
the prayer says at the end.
Well, when did the mourning
process end?
Is the war of 1914/1918 over,
as many felt in the early
1990s, after the fall of the
Wall of Berlin?
Paradoxically,
in the last few years we have
witnessed a new emotional
investment in the conflict,
the first and the fourth
generation, the generations of
the veterans' grandchildren or
great-grandchildren--my
generation and your
generation--are more and more
aware of the importance of the
Great War in the history of the
twentieth century,
and the First World War tends
to be ever more present in the
minds of successive generations.
According to most historians,
and according especially to
Stéphane Audoin-Rouzeau,
this renewed interest in the
1990s is related to the
unfinished process of mourning,
and actually explains that by
the number of many missing in
action in World War One.
At the end of the 1920s,
after the death of Maurice's
father, Berthe Gallais decided
to transform her house so that
it could be transformed into a
kind of museum.
So, she was living--she moved.
She lived in a small house just
opposite what had become the
Musée Maurice Gallais,
founded in the 1930s;
and she died in 1956.
Was this transformation of the
house into a museum a way for
her to show that the mourning
process was over,
or on the contrary was it a way
to prolong the mourning process
eternally?
Anyway, after so many years
Maurice's room remains unchanged
as a kind of private chapel in a
public museum.
Thanks.